so we're at the Black match booth now
and it's cool it's just like you know
last year except now it's this year
this reminds me of the beginning of Team
America
near the lighted your favorite here the
classic tutorial beginning this year
hey what's up Andrew Kramer here with
another very exciting tutorial well
let's take the tour you get it work with
even smaller channels that are oh yeah
once you over to subscribers three
subscribers we see sort of a tragedy in
the YouTube business model low costs
high volume content pranks beauty vlogs
however quarter digital is a great
example is something that almost never
happens and that creators are able to do
something that's more narrative and
story and visual based we see sort of a
lack of support in the market so we want
to focus on that area where you can
actually add a lot of value because of
the production resources and everything
that we do have here
this party is kicking so oh my god three
separate stages and a whole bunch of
stands that's apartment set standing bar
set so as you can see free wall site
created off it's like really easy to
build sets and pretty much do whatever
you need to film something simply we
like the idea of cheap efficient
production six episodes in a day just
knock it out you mean curtain around so
you can green up the entire site is a
thing it's all there's a curtain in here
also a giant hallway yeah this is door
that's our page so we own all relating
inventory grip electric distro pretty
much anything you ever need to do a job
if we don't have it here
we've got long-standing relationships of
every rental house so we'll get to a
good price awesome oh my god okay please
Wow seconds good huh I don't want to get
rested up awkward running awkward
awkward like half job run anyways every
single year people are trying to grasp
for new technology new things and new
ways to do this stuff there's 8k cameras
4k 60 cameras and monitors and stuff so
it's kind of like that whole game of
dynamic range in digital video cameras
is kind of over now because the good
cameras exist and they're reasonably
affordable so yeah I think every goddamn
lady why is nobody come out with like a
solid focus playing solution for Canon
lenses their electronic lenses right why
is there not just needs a little dial
that connects to the camera's lens
control system just let you pull focus
wirelessly why is that not exist so
angry they've Canon lenses on the
scarlet so why is there not just a
little dial that lets you pull winds
like or pull focus on those lenses you
control it on the camera this little you
can set the buttons let you do it
wireless monitoring what the heck's up
with that guys come on let's get on it
here's the thing they don't tell you
about Gimbels every time you have one
you need a second camera for when things
aren't on a gimbal because when you put
a camera on a cable yet to balance it
and that's a pain in the butt I will say
though DJI is raw camera recorder on top
of the Osmo that's pretty cool that's
why I think the picture of filmic is
going to go towards so also Blackmagic
mini high if it ever comes out will be a
great camera for all II need filmmakers
out there it looks great the thing about
this and I'll say it on camera where we
provide this specifically to our
creators at no price we are very very
happy to offer when it's not being used
to empower creators who really do
believe in the value of that but someone
wants to come in and pay several
thousand dollars to use the stage we're
gonna take the money so it's not just to
come in and use it for free I don't want
to set the wrong expectation that wasn't
that wasn't accurate the creator space
over there too you get an entire
equipment room yeah so I was like
there's a bunch of genie lighting and
all that kind of stuff you know again
everything that you would probably need
to do a high quality film that you're
not going to get anywhere else
Gigi Gigi everyone we lost Niko where is
Niko I don't he's like do you feel like
really interested in like all the boring
stuff he was looking at those radios man
doesn't tennis yeah he got he concocted
like a 15-foot antenna that blew his
mind and since we pulled out of the
behind though and told us to be honest
dude I asked for an 8-foot antenna for
Christmas and I only got a six foot one
oh hi I know sorry I know that
disappointment you're like almost I know
it's made out of aluminum
doesn't even conduct electricity well
yes lieutenant newbs is a decorative
antenna well we got the statement of
work as soon as I click send on this
email we're good
you don't mind if we shoot a little bit
yeah go forward so you do not where you
saying things you're most comfortable
with
/ feel I care most I guess talented at
one of the things that you feel like
you're a week is that in one yes yes but
I can do like
for that
that's the extent of my martial arts
thank you no autographs please